bueno fue un traslado que duró mucho más
de lo que nos habían dicho no se tenía
programado que durará unos 20 minutos en
realidad desde hollywood house desde ese
palacio en donde el féretro estuvo a lo
largo del día de la tarde noche de ayer
perdón hasta esta tarde y pues es todo
ese recorrido hasta aquí hasta la
catedral de sant dios pero duro en
realidad de unos 45 minutos
prácticamente todo este recorrido con
miles de personas de lado y lado del
rollo mayor de esta avenida principal
aquí en edimburgo en el casco antiguo de
la capital escocesa y pues ya hace unos
instantes comenzó esta ceremonia aquí
que está siendo llevada a cabo por el
reverendo alemán más libre en todo caso
ya una vez que el féretro
ingresó a la catedral la mayoría de las
personas pues se ha habido un poco más
ya de movimiento se han vaciado un
poquito con las calles alrededor
esperando la gente también de hecho pues
hay unos parlantes sea a través de los
cuales alcanzamos a escuchar que sea
ustedes alcanzan a escuchar un poco la
ceremonia en todo caso tenemos el sonido
de lo que está sucediendo al interior de
esta catedral y pues fue una procesión
con un silencio solemne y algunos
aplausos mientras el paso de todo este
cortejo fúnebre detrás de este coche
fúnebre que llevaba al féretro de la
reina isabel envuelto en el estandarte
real de escocia después iba el rey a
carlos junto con el resto de sus
hermanos que se esperó natalia para las
próximas horas
bueno después de esta ceremonia será el
rey carlos quien irá al parlamento de
escocia allí pues serán los principales
políticos principales jefes de los
partidos políticos escoceses quienes
pues le darán un discurso de
condolencias luego vendrá la respuesta
del rey de carlos tercero y luego vendrá
toda la digamos la velación serán los
hijos de la reina isabel quienes velen
el cuerpo aquí en la catedral de
ascendidos y luego sobre las cinco de la
tarde -hora local- más o menos
aproximadamente pues ya las personas
podrán comenzar a ingresar a la catedral
durante casi unas 24 horas
las personas pues que han venido
teniendo su ciudad están haciendo ya
fila para poder ingresar en algún
momento de esta tarde claro natalia
gracias por la información